South Korea's news agency says diplomacy
is now at a crossroads between the u.s.
and North Korea let's check in on the
mood there after the hasty end to this
summit senior foreign affairs
correspondent Greg Powell khat is in
Seoul again this morning it was not the
result the region was looking for folks
in Seoul and elsewhere watched as
president Trump and Kim jong-un walked
away from the summit in Hanoi without a
deal
the South Korean government expressed
its regrets it's unfortunate that US
president Trump and North Korean
Chairman Kim jong-un did not reach a
complete agreement in today's summit
meeting set aside for now a possible end
of Korean War declaration a resumption
of inter-korean economic projects and
possibly a planned visit to Seoul by Kim
jong-un following South Korean president
moons trip to the north on the phone
with President Trump moon was told
dialogue between the u.s. and North
Korea would continue and a freeze on its
missile launches and nuclear testing
would remain along with the dispute over
sanctions Pyongyang was not willing to
go far enough to satisfy the u.s.
regarding its nuclear program that
worries North Korean ally China woman
fetus we hope that the Democratic
People's Republic of Korea and the
United States will continue to work
together to promote the denuclearization
of the peninsula president Trump has
been trying to coax his North Korean
partner into giving up his nukes by
citing the economic success of regional
neighbors like summit post Vietnam while
most analysts agree Kim jong-un is
determined to modernize as backward
country some say he needs his nuclear
arsenal to feel secure no matter how
rich North Koreans become you know debt
people cannot be rich he wants to be
first dead be mere happy real and he
believes that he needs nuclear weapons
for his physical and political survival
yes
president Trump reportedly asked South
Korean president moon to once again act
as mediator between the United States
and North Korea with his own country
security on the line no doubt moon will
accept Brett Gregg danke live in Seoul
Gregg thank you